so a lot of people ask me in fact ask me
every day like how do you get your
protein how come you're not anemic
aren't you missing you know certain
vitamins and minerals how do you get
your essential fatty acids and basically
all of those issues can be addressed on
a plant-based whole food diet if you're
just a little bit more aware and
conscious of what you're eating so for
example a little-known fact quinoa which
is it's actually a seed although it
tastes more like a grain it tastes like
a sprouted grain but I think it's
derivation is actually C it's a it's
it's quite high in protein for a
plant-based food so I eat a lot of this
sometimes even eat it for breakfast you
can boil it down like a grain put it in
the refrigerator overnight put coconut
milk on and blueberries in the morning
eat it for a beautiful breakfast it's
great also you can make it for dinner
put it over brown rice or as a side dish
the other thing is iron a lot of people
say oh my god you must be anemic like
how do you produce hemoglobin like and
there are certain people that are
vegetarian and vegan that do have an
issue with anemia so you do have to be a
little bit more aware of where you're
getting your iron so one great source of
iron on a plant-based diet is pumpkin
seeds sometimes they're called pepitas
in the market so we use a lot of these
in our blended drinks and I actually
keep a bag of these in my car and I'm
kind of munching on them quite a bit so
that I always know that I'm getting the
other things black seeds we a lot of
these these are high in essential fatty
acids and you can put these over a salad
or you can put
morning one to drink either this or you
can get flexi oil as well same thing but
reflections are great sweet wanna put
them in our bananas go